Speaker 1: Congresswoman Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
is calling for the expulsion of Republicans
involved in the planning of the Trump riot. We
now have, as we talked about in the last segment.
The allegations are from two slash three sources
who spoke to Hunter Walker for Rolling Stone
about the involvement of Marjorie Taylor Greene,
Madison Cawthorn, Lauren Boebert, Paul Gosar,
Louie Gohmert, Andy Biggs. Maybe I'm forgetting
one in the planning of the January 6th protests,
which turned riotous. Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
now says anybody who's involved should be
kicked out of the House of Representatives
kicked out of Congress. A Newsweek reporting.
Congresswoman Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez called
for the expulsion of any member of Congress who
helped plan the storming of the U.S. Capitol
after a bombshell report alleged that several
Republican lawmakers had coordinated with rally
organizers. Her comment came after a Rolling
Stone report published Sunday night claimed
multiple members had been intimately involved
in the planning of former President Donald
Trump's efforts to overturn his election loss
and the Jan. six protests, which culminated in the
violence at the U.S. Capitol. She tweeted Quote
Any member of Congress who helped plot a terrorist
attack on our nation's Capitol must be expelled.
This was a terror attack. One hundred and thirty
eight injured. Almost 10 dead. Those responsible
remain a danger to our democracy, our country
and human life in the vicinity of our Capitol
and beyond. Now I would actually go a step
further. Expulsion actually isn't enough. AOC
can only deal with the expulsion part because
she's not law enforcement. She's a legislator,
but it actually isn't enough. We should be talking
about criminal charges here, if applicable,
when the evidence points to that. What I mean is
there should not be a now criminal charges now
because these are members of Congress.
It needs to be looked at as if these were
any other people. Now, realistically,
we're not going to see the expulsion. AOC
is right. We should see it. We're not going
to see it. It would take a two thirds vote
to expel any member. This will never happen, given
the narrow margins. Instead, what probably needs
to happen is the prosecution needs to happen and
then that will make these. Folks ineligible in
theory, if convicted and immediately removed,
it's easier, I believe, to convince. I don't
know if it would be six people if these would
be 12 12 person, probably 12 person juries,
although, you know, it depends on a lot of a lot
of particulars. It's easier to convince 12 people
off the street than it would be to convince highly
Partizan actors in the House of Representatives
to vote to expel their own to their own
detriment by flipping the balance of power
further against their own party. So that's just
the reality. AOC completely right. We are only in
stage like zero point one in figuring out what the
fallout and what the repercussions are going to be
from these incredible allegations based on
this Rolling Stone piece by Hunter Walker.
But AOC completely right. Law enforcement and the
justice system needs to be ready to go as well.
These people deserve to go down for
this, and one of the real problems that
makes me worried there's likely to be more of this
the next time they don't like an election result
is that there have not been serious consequences.
Yes, we started to see some verdicts and OK,
there are people who are going to have to do a
few years. But for the political figures involved,
no consequences whatsoever. And we're going to
now see if this will push things over the edge.
We know that this congressional committee has been
investigating and looking at this evidence, but as
law enforcement looking at it is the Department
of Justice looking at it, Joe Biden shouldn't
get involved the way he hasn't. But it should be
looked at. We're going to follow it. Let me know
your thoughts about all of this via Twitter,
where you can find me at De Pacman on Twitter.